قدم مبعوث الامم المتحده الى ليبيا عبد
الله باتيلي مبادره لاجراء الانتخابات
التي قال انه لا يستبعد وضع خارطه طريق
لها بحلول يونيو المقبل وحذر بديل من ان
يقود استمرار الوضع الحالي لتقويض وحده
ليبيا ارضا وشعبا من جانبهما اكد رئيس
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه والمجلس الاعلى
للدوله دعمهما اجراء الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات الى اي حد نجحت مبادره
المبعوث الاممي في تقديم حلول ترضي اطراف
الازمه الليبيه وتوفر حلا للاشكالات التي
تحول دون اتفاقهم وكيف ستتعاطى الاطراف
الليبيه المختلفه مع هذه المبادره وما مدى
قدره مؤسسات الدوله الحاليه على الدفع
باتجاه انتخابات ستعيد صياغه مراكز القوى
حسب المبادره وما فرص نجاح هذه المبادره
وما النتائج التي قد تترتب على فشلها
والمسارات البديله للبلاد اذا اصر كل طرف
في الازمه على التمسك بموقفه
[موسيقى]
المؤتمر الصحفي الذي عقده السبت في
العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس لتقديم مبادره
للحل كان قد كشف عنها في السابع والعشرين
من الشهر الماضي خلال احاطه امام مجلس
الامن الدولي اعلن رئيس بعثه الامم
المتحده للدعم في ليبيا عبد الله بتيلي
مبادره لاجراء الانتخابات قال انه
بالامكاني وضعه خارطه طريق للانتخابات
بحلول منتصف يونيو حزيران القادم وان
المبادره جاءت بعد طلبات تقدم بها لكافه
اطراف الازمه الليبيه بشان مقترحاتهم لحل
الازمه اما اهم بنود مبادره المبعوث
الاممي الى ليبيا فهي انشاء لجنه توجيهيه
رفيعه المستوى هدفها اجراء الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والتشريعيه خلال العام الجاري
وستعمل الاليه المقترحه على الجمع بين
مختلف الاطراف الليبيه بمن فيهم ممثله
والمؤسسات السياسيه وزعماء القبائل
ومنظمات المجتمع المدني والاطراف الامنيه
وممثلون عن النساء والشباب
اللجنه المقترحه ستعمل ايضا على تيسير
اعتماد اطار قانوني وجدول زمني ملزم
لاجراء الانتخابات كما توفر اللجنه منصه
لتعزيز الاجماع حول قضايا تامين
الانتخابات واعتماد ميثاق شرف لجميع
المرشحين
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من اسطنبول نزار
مدير مركز بيانا للدراسات السياسيه في
ليبيا ومن لندن بيتر السفير البريطانيه
السابق لدى بريطانيا اهلا وسهلا بكم سيد
نزار ابدا منك هذه المبادره الى اي مدى
يمكن ان تسهم في ان يكون حل
لما تمر به ليبيا
اهلا وسهلا اظن ان كلمه حل كبيره اعلى هذه
المبادره لان هي الان تضع اطار عام هو
حاول بتي لان يضع تاطير لما قام به مجلس
الاعلى للدوله ومجلس النواب وحاول ان يفسر
اكثر بوضوح مبادرته فبالتالي هو الان يريد
ان يؤطر ويحاول من خلال هذا الاطار الجديد
ان يحيي العمليه السياسيه بان يحفظ ماء
وجه المجلس الاعلى للدوله ومجلس النواب
وان يتماشى معهما وان يظهر للشعب الليبي
انه لا يريد ان يختطف الازمه منهم لانه
بعد تقديمه لمبادرته ظهرت اصوات تتحدث عن
ان بتيل يريد ان يكون ينزع الملكيه
المحليه للازمه الليبيه فحاول ان يبرر ذلك
ويفسر مبادرته بانها دعم لاطار مجلس اعلى
الدوله مجلس النواب واذا عادت الكره لمجلس
الاعلى للدوله ومجلس النواب فان هي الازمه
لا يوجد حركه حقيقيه يعني نحن نرى تحركا
يعني فيه حركه ولكن لا هنا ليس هناك
التطور في الازمه من مستوى الى اخر التطور
الوحيد الذي يبدو انه قد يكون مرحله جديده
هو اطار الزمن اللي وضعه في شهر سته لكن
لا اظن ان كل هذه الامور قد مست جوهر
الازمه الليبيه وانما حاولت ان تدفعها
دفعه نحو الاتجاه الصحيح وهو ان يكون هناك
في اطار زمني ويبدو ان عبد الله بتيل قد
تواصل مع روسيا وتواصل مع مصر ويبدو ان
هناك محاوله ووعد من روسيا خاصه بعد جلسته
مجلس الامن وبعد زيارته لهم بان يكون هناك
تعاطي ايجابي معه ووصلوا لحل وسط هذا الحل
الوسط هو ان يكون هناك فرصه للمجلس الاعلى
للدوله ومجلس النواب نهايتها في شهر 6 اذا
توافقوا وكان هناك قانون انتخابات فانه
سينضي في الانتخابات وفقا لقانون مجلس
الاعلى للدوله ومجلس النواب فهو استفاد من
ذلك شيئين اثنين الاول انه ضغط على المجلس
الاعلى للدوله ومجلس النواب وحفظ لهما
مكانتهما وفي نفس الوقت
ظهر بانه هو من يضع الاجنده في ليبيا وهذا
يعطيه قوه حتى ان القوه السياسيه ممكن ان
تتعامل معه ولم يخسر مبادرته بالكامل انما
وضع لجنه سماها اللجنه
يعني العليا او شيء من هذا الاسم بان تكون
هي التي تضع ميثاق الشرف وتضع الاطار
القانوني وتعزز الاجماع وتمنع الاختلاف كل
هذه القضايا هي قضايا ليس لها اي صيغه
قانونيه فوضعت فقط للدفع العمليه السياسيه
لكن ما لم يضع لهذه اللجنه صيغه قانونيه
فهي بلا معنى لان اذا قررت يعني لا راي
لمن لا يطاع كما يقال فبالتالي الان هو
مجلس اعلى الدوله ومجلس النواب الكره في
ملعبهما وبتيلي يسندهما الى شهر سته ويبدو
ان هذا اتفاق دولي يعطي هذين المجلسين
فرصه الى حين الذهاب اما الى انتخابات
واما ان يكون هناك خارطه طريق جديده هذه
الخارطه يبدو ان بديل يسعى اليها من الان
لانه لا يعني الان نتحدث عن خاله الطريق
انه ينتظر المجلس الاعلى للدوله ومجلس
النواب انما يسعى لخطه بديله يقدمها اذا
فشل هذين المجلسين بطريقه اخرى ان مصر
وروسيا قالت له نعطيهما الى شهر سته وبعد
ذلك لكل حادث
وانت كنت السفير البريطاني السابق لدى
ليبيا ومطلع على هذا الملف الى اي مدى ترى
ان مبادره السيد باتيلي تسهم في ايجاد
ايجاد حل للازمه الليبيه
اعتقد
خطوه بالاتجاه الصحيح واتفق مع السيد
كريكش ان المشروعيه لها اهميه قصوى في هذه
المساله واضح ان الحل لا يمكن ان يفرض من
قبل السيد باتيلي او اي طرف خارجي وانا
الاحظ ان السيد باتيلي اشار الى اهميه
امتلاك ليبيا لهذا المشروع ايا كانت
اللجنه التي يتحدث عنها هناك الكثير من
الاطراف المعنيه التي يمكن ان تدخل في
عضويتها لكن على ما يبدي هو يسعى الى
الحصول على موافقه اطياف واسعه اذا ما تم
ذلك هذا سيكون خطوه
ايجابيه
وطبعا الامر سيعتمد على
اللاعبين والمساهمين
نتذكر قبل ضحو عامين من الان مليونين
والنصف مليون
متوقعا ان تتم في نهايه العام 2021 ذلك لم
يحدث لاسباب عديده ويبدو لي ان الشعب
الليبي نفسه يريد ان يكون له صوت في
الكيفيه التي يحكم فيها بلده ويسعى لقياده
سياسيه جيده هذا امر يجب ان يدعمه المجتمع
الدولي لكن في خاتمه المطاف الامر متروك
لليبيين ليتوصلوا الى توافق حول تفاصيل
هذه الامور اي قواعد انتخابيه اي نظام
انتخابي
قوانين هذه كلها يجب ان تتم بسرعه اعتبار
اطار زمني بشهر سته يؤدي الى انتخابات في
النهايه يبدو لي طموحا اكثر مما ينبغي
لكنه على الاقل محاوله جيده وصولا الى
انتخابات ذات مشروعيه في هذا العام طبعا
رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه الليبيه عبد
الحميد الدبيبه رحب بجهود المبعوث الاممي
لوضع خارطه الطريق للانتخابات واشاد في
تغريده له باستجابه الامم المتحده لطلب
رفع مستوى التنسيق والدعم المقدم في مسار
التحضير والاستعداد للانتخابات كما نشد
الليبيين التحلي بالاراده القويه لانهاء
المراحل الانتقاليه عبر انتخابات عادله
ونزيهه سيد نزار كريكش كيف تتوقع ان
تتعامل الاجسام السياسيه المختلفه مع
مبادره باتيلي وهو الذي من الناحيه اشاد
بها ولكن في ذات الوقت يعتبر انها هي سبب
الازمه
وهذا يعني امر طريف شاهدناه اليوم يعني
البحث هي اشبه بمن يحفظ ماء وجه الجميع
هذا المقترح الذي قدمه باتيلي كل طرف فهمه
بطريقه يريد ان يعني في مضمونه انه هو هذا
ما كنت اقوله هذا هو الراي الصواب عبد
الحميد بيبه يقول بان كنت اقول من البدايه
بانها الانتخابات تحتاج الى قوانين نزيهه
وعادله وشفافه فبالتالي هو يريد ان يقول
بان ما قاله بتيل يذهب مع رايي بان القصور
عند مجلس النواب مجلس الاعلى للدوله
السيد المشتري يقول بان نحن مستعدون
لاجراء الانتخابات فبالتالي اريد ان يقول
بان نحن اجرينا التعديل الدستوري الثالث
عشر ونحن جاهزون لتشكيل اللجنه في في طبعا
في شهر سته طبعا في نقطه ذكرها عبد الله
لتبين ان هو بتيلي نفسه يعني غير مرتاح
لفكره ان المجلس الاعلى للدوله مجلس
النواب هم من يتولوا الامر عندما قال بان
هذه الاجسام هي انتهت ولايتها وان هي سبب
عدم الاستقرار وان كذلك بان المجلس من
الاعلى للدوله والواب عليهما ان ينجز
الامر في شهر سته والا نحن مستعدون لوضع
خلط الطريق فكان فيه يعني يعني كان فيه
خلاف حصل بين كل هذه المجالس وحل اما من
اطراف دوليه او بنقاشات
حلت يعني وضعت كل طرف اعطته خيط منها حل
هذه المشكله المجلس الاعلى للدوله ومجلس
النواب اصبحوا هما قياده شرعيه يعني قياده
تملك السلطه التشريعيه لوضع قوانين
انتخابات الحكومه يبدو انها ستبقى لان
هناك شهرين فقط للمجلس الاعلى للدوله
ومجلس النواب فبالتالي لن تطرح مساله
تغيير الحكومه فهو يعني فيه وزن
لايجاد ميزان للقوى السياسيه في ليبيا اظن
ان هذا جديد يعني في تفكير جديد من عبد
الله بتيلي وفيه مشاورات
الخطه ما زال ملامحها غير واضحه لانها هي
ستعتمد على قضايا اساسيه في قانون
الانتخابات لقضايا المتعلقه بازدواجيه
الجنسيه والقضايا العسكريه لكنه اشار في
الملتقى كذلك اليوم الذي قال بانه لا يمكن
ان يمنع احد من هذه الانتخابات فبالتالي
الان هناك فكره او تصور جديد نفسي دافع
نفسي للجميع للتفكير في الانتخابات وهنا
سيدخل الجميع لحلبه السياسه وهذا ما يريد
المجتمع الدولي في الحقيقه يريد ان يكون
الصراع صراع سياسي ويؤطر رويدا رويدا من
خلال مجموع القوانين ليضع المجلس الاعلى
للدوله ومجلس النواب تحت ضغط البعثه بان
تكون البعثه تقول لهم انتم امامكم شهرين
فقط اظن هذه خطوات عمليه تحركت حركه
المياه الراكده في ليبيا
طبعا قام بهذه المبادره كما قال بعد
مشاوره كل الاطراف هل تعتقد ان المؤسسات
الليبيه الموجوده الان لديها الرغبه
والقدره على الدفع باتجاه انت خابات بناء
على مبادره عبد الله بتيل
اعتقد ان كل اصحاب المصلحه الذين تحدث
اليهم هم دائما تعاملوا مع الامه المتحده
بعضهم كانت لديه تحفظات وبعضهم يرون
المبادره الجديده او الانتخابات كمصدر خطر
لكن عليه ان يركز على ما يريده الشعب
الليبي نفسه هذا هو ما هو مهم للغايه
واعتقدوا كذلك ان واحده من الدروس التي
تعلمناها من مبادرات سابقه هو ان لا نركز
بشكل حصري على المسار السياسي هناك ايضا
مسار عسكري هناك
مجموعات عليها ان تلتزم بوقف اطلاق النار
لكن ما يهم المواطن الذي هو المسار
الاقتصادي انا صادفه وان كنت ادير المج
الاقتصادي الليبي البريطاني نحن لسنا
رابطه سياسيه نحن رابط اقتصاديه اعلم ان
هناك ليبيين كثيرين يريدون من بريطانيا ان
تاتي تساعدهم في مجال الاصلاح الاقتصادي
وايضا مساله تاميم المصادر النفطره وما
الى ذلك
القطاع الخاص الذي اعتقد انه سيوفر فرص
تشغيل هائله تنويع مصادر الدخل الاقتصادي
له اهميه حيويه هذه مهمه على الامم
المتحده ان تركز على كل هؤلاء وكل هذه
النشاطات المختلفه في سعيها لحل الموضوع
في ردود الفعل الليبيه على مبادره باتيلي
رحب رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه الليبيه
عبد الحميد دبيبه بجهود باتيلي لوضع خارطه
الطريق للانتخابات اضاف انما سماه تعبير
المجتمع الدولي عن خيبه امله من جديه جهات
التشريعيه في الانتخابات يتسق مع موقف
حكومته واضافت بيبه ان مشكله الانتخابات
هي قصور الجهات التشريعيه في ايجاد قوانين
قابله للتنفيذ وعادله ونزيهه اما رئيس
المجلس الاعلى للدوله خالد المشري فقال ان
لديهم اراده سياسيه قويه لاجراء
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه قبل
نهايه العام الجاري
تحدث سيد نزار كريكش عن مساله ازدواجيه
الجنسيه وترشح العسكريين هل هذه
قابله للحل هل تعتقد انه يمكن التوافق
عليها ام ستظل العقبه
الالمانعه
للتوصل الى توافق بين الليبيين
اشكاليه حقيقيه يعني ولكن
وفقا لبعض المعلومات لانها الاغلب القوه
الدوليه التي يعني تتدخل في الشان الليبي
او تحاول ان توفق بين اطراف الليبيه تطرح
اسئله واضحه بانها حفتر الان موجود في
الشرق فبالتالي كيف يمكن ان منعه من
الترشح للانتخابات يبدو ان في قناعه بدات
تتشكل عند القوه السياسيه لان المشهد الان
ليس قبل خمس سنوات هناك كثير من القوه
الغربيه توجهت نحو حفتر فتحي بشاغه الذي
كان في يوم من الايام يقاتل حفتر الان هو
رئيس وزراء وموجود في بنغازي بعض القوى
الاسلاميه زي الحزب الديمقراطي ومن يعني
الكتله الموجوده في مجلس الاعلى للدوله لا
ترى غضاضه في التعامل مع حفتر
بقيت بعض الاطراف الاخرى التي ستظهر رفضت
هذا الامر ستظهر وكانها تعيق الانتخابات
فاذا الان اظن ان لم يكن هناك حل وسط في
هذه المساله
سيترك الامر الى اللجنه واللجنه اظن انها
تشترط على كل من يريد الترشح اما ان
يستقيل من القوات العسكريه قبل الانتخابات
بثلاثه اشهر وان تترك مساله الجنسيه يعني
سيكون هناك اخذ وعطاء في هذه الشروط الان
الوضع مهيا
للمضيف في مجال انتخابات والقبول حتى بحفر
في هذه الانتخابات طبعا سيواجه هذا
بمعارضه كبيره لا احد يعرف مداها لان
القوه الغربيه حفتر ما فعله في الغرب وفي
الشرق ليس بالامر الهين واظن ان ما زال ما
دام في سلاح سيكون هناك رغبه من هذه
الاطراف في في تقويه
كلماتها ومعارضتها لحفتر هنا سياتي دور
القوه الدوليه ودول الحلفاء بمحاوله الضغط
على الاطراف السياسيه اللي بيقول الاطراف
المستفيده من الوضع السياسي والاقتصادي في
ليبيا لان الان من يحرك المشهد هي مجموعه
شبكات مصالح في ليبيا وهذه المجموعه
الشبكات لها علاقه بمجموع الميليشيات اذا
استطاعت هذه الحركه الشبكه المتكونه في
ليبيا بالضغط على الاطراف السياسيه
والمليشيات العسكريه للقبول بالانتخابات
ان الانتخابات اظن ستمضي لكن سيكون العقبه
اداء الحقيقيه بعد نتيجه الانتخابات كيف
سيكون الامر ان لم تكن هناك صفقه من تحت
الطاوله الان قسمت فيها كل المناصب فاظن
ان الامر سيكون صعب على ليبيا وسنعود الى
نقطه الصفر من جديد
الفاعله في ليبيا ماذا سوف يكون
دورها وفي اي اتجاه ستدفع
اعتقد ان من المهم للمجتمع الدولي ان
يتكلم بصوت موحد وان يدعم المتحده والسيد
باتيلي هذه هي اللعبه الوحيده
المتاحه
ودعمه وشعوره هو بانه يحظى بهذا الدعم
الواسع النطاق من المجتمع الدولي هو رساله
مهمه بحد ذاته كما ان من الاهميه بمكان كل
الامور التي تحدثنا عنها حول ترشيح بعض
الاشخاص ام لا هذه قضيه يجب ان تترك للشعب
الليبي ليحسن لكن دور المجتمع الدولي لا
يكون لا ينبغي ان يكون عبر التدخل بل عن
طريق توفير اطار للدعم اطار للدعم لاصلاح
سياسي وعسكري واقتصادي
لتوفير الخبرات والم عرفه عندما يطلبها
لبيونه انفسهم لتفادي اي تصورات بان
الحلول تفرض من الخارج سيد عبدالله بتيلي
مبعوث الامم المتحده الى ليبيا حذر في
سياق طرح مبادرته من خطوره اطاله امد
الوضع الحالي في ليبيا على سلامه اراضي
ليبيا وعلى وحده شعبها
الترتيبات المؤقته المتتاليه والحكومه
الانتقاليه المستمره الى ما لا نهايه
والاجسام التشريعيه التي انتهت ولايتها هي
سبب عدم الاستقرار الذي يعرض هذا البلد
للخطر اطاله امد هذا الوضع لن تؤدي الا
الى الانهيار الاقتصادي والاضطرابات
السياسيه والاجتماعيه وتفاقم حاله انعدام
الامن وكل ذلك سيؤدي في نهايه المطاف الى
تقويد سلامه اراضي ليبيا ووحده شعبها
ما فرص هذه المبادره في النجاح وانها لم
تنجح فما هي البدائل
[موسيقى]
صعوبه بمكان ان نحكم على هذه المبادره هل
ستنجح ام لا الانطباع الذي يتولد ولديه هو
ان الليبيين انفسهم يريدون لها النجاح
لانهم يريدون ان يحكموا انفسهم بانفسهم
وهناك دعم دولي كبير من الولايات المتحده
المملكه المتحده والمانيا وفرنسا وهكذا
وهناك زخم
يتكون ما وراء الكواليس دعما لهذه
المبادره وبكل صراحه لا ارى ايه بداء
العدد عن استمرار المازق واستمرار خيبه
امل الشعب الليبي الذي يريد ان يرى
انتخابات ويدلي بصوته فيها ايضا بالنسبه
الاصلاح الاقتصادي
لاخراج القوات الاجنبيه كل هذه الامور طلب
حكومه موحده
تحظى بصفه الاحتراف في كل انحاء ليبيا
والمجتمع الدولي هذا سيوفر فرص الاستقرار
والازدهار للمواطن الليبي سيد نزار هل
هناك ما تغير في البيئه المحليه او
الاقليميه يمكن ان يعني يجعل هذه المبادره
مبادره ناجحه
يعني ليس هناك تغيرات كبيره او ان تغير
الوحيد هو ان الادراك الجميع باهميه ليبيا
خاصه القوى الغربيه بان ادركت بان ليبيا
مهمه بعد حرب اوكرانيا وان ما يحدث من
الفاجنر في في جنوب ليبيا قد يؤثر في في
نفوذ امريكا والفرنسا والقوه الغربيه في
في افريقيا فبالتالي هم الان اكثر جديه
واكثر وضوح واتضح للجميع بان ليبيا مهمه
جدا بعد يعني حرب اوكرانيا وازمه الغاز
وازمه الهجره
وتوهل فاغنر في تشاد وفي افريقيا الوسطى
وفي السودان هذه الامور اصبحت واضحه
للجميع فهذا اعطى جديه لهذه الدول ان تكون
تدخلها تدخل ايجابي على الاقل في الحد
الادنى الذي يحفظ التوازن لكن ما يعكر هذا
الامر هو روسيا نفسها التي ستظل هي تحاول
ان تعيق كل تقدم في الملف الليبي ان لم
يكن يصب في صالحها فاذا لم يصب في صالحها
فانها ستحاول ان تدعم كل الاطراف التي
تساعدها من اجل
الاطراف المختلفه اذا اصرت الاطراف
المختلفه على التمسك بمواقفها ماذا يمكن
ان تكون المسارات البديله
نعم اظن ان المسارات طبعا حتكون صعبه على
ليبيا لان الان اذا استمرت هذه الازمه في
اوكرانيا والازمه الاقليميه فان التدخلات
ستكون اكثر صفورا اكثر وضوحا وقد يكون
هناك نزاع حول افريقيا في ليبيا وهذا
بدايه لنزاع اكبر بين روسيا والصين
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه فاذا لم
تستقر ليبيا الان وكانت في مسار
دوله يدعمها حتى من القوى الغربيه اقصد
اوروبا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه فان
روسيا ستتدخل بقوه سيكون هناك نزاع اكبر
ستتحول نزاعات الموجوده في الشرق الاوسط
الى شمال افريقيا وسندخل في في نزاع كبير
جدا هو نزاع دولي في الحقيقه يعني
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لكما من اسطنبول نزار
كريكش مدير مركز بيان للدراسات السياسيه
في ليبيا وكان معنا من لندن بيتر ميليت
السفير البريطانيه السابق الاداريه شكرا
جزيلا
الى هنا مشاهدينا الكرام تنتهي هذه الحلقه
من برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لكم على
المتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]